all right we
are now live for the ama this is for
august 2020 so i've already got a lot of
questions lined up beginning with an
interesting one uh coming from matthew
in your view what are some of the most
impressive philosophers of the last 50
years
and why so impressive is kind of a
tough thing to work with i guess you
know
i'm gonna take it in the direction of
those who've made the biggest impression
upon me
and i would say that you know in in my
view
you can say that there's like
philosophers who are
trying to do you know
groundbreaking work uh usually failing
in that
um because most of the stuff that that
seems to be like absolutely new
turns out not to be it's already been
done in one way or
another and the people just didn't read
enough but there are people who make
some really interesting contributions
and i'm really partial as i know a lot
of you already
are aware of of i'm really partial to
people who are grounded in the history
of philosophy
and not grounded in the sense of being
sort of pettiness or they've got their
own little
you know schtick that they're doing i
only do cartesianism i mean people who
actually understand
the sort of the broad sweep and have
have lent their minds to
people like descartes or aristotle or
mary wollstonecraft or nietzsche for an
extended period of time and have sort of
thoroughly understood their work and so
i mean the first person that comes to
mind for me for that is aleister
mcintyre somebody who
i've always found his works to be quite
quite useful although there's places
where i disagree with him
um or i think that he's left something
out
but on the whole i find his his work uh
really
interesting and engaging and very often
on point
um and i can say from having interacted
with him that when it comes to virtue
ethics he's the real deal
he walks the walk a lot of people who
are in the
history of philosophy i have a great
appreciation for
julia anas you know margaret graver
chris gill all of people who i've had
the opportunity to interact with
there's a lot of younger scholars uh and
when i say younger i mean you know
my age or younger so we're attacking you
know i'm turning 50 this month
uh there's a lot of great talent out
there in the history of philosophy
if we're talking about people that are
viewed as like being more original or
something
that are have impressed me i mean jurgen
habermas is certainly one of them
um who else sort of like pops to mind in
the last
50 years um
that's a good question you know i i
don't stay
on top of cutting-edge stuff anymore
um i'm i spend much more time with you
know primary texts of earlier thinkers
so maybe i'm not a good good person to
ask about about that that would be a
good thing to ask
who ask other people who they're
impressed with
all right uh gutter ground asked a bunch
of questions i asked him to narrow it
down to one
and he picked the one that i don't have
a good answer to
is there a version of eliminative
materialism that takes complexity theory
emergence into account
my understanding is it's completely
reductive i don't know because i don't i
don't really
read a lot of people who identify
themselves as reductive materialists
um other than people in you know past
history and it strikes me that if you're
doing a very reductive let's you know
boil
everything down to simple stuff as we
can and
you know screw everything else uh you're
probably not going to be about emergence
you're going to see that as a little bit
too you know
to to loose you gucci for you and that
you know that would hold whether
you were an old school positivist or
whatever
um so i don't i don't know that's that's
not an area i really
do a lot of work in so
it might be better to like stick with uh
stuff that you know that i i'm working
on
all right intellectual jujitsu in a
previous video you seem to dismiss the
notion that university faculty and admin
are disproportionately liberal or
left-wing what do you think of alan
bloom's thesis
in the closing of the american mind so
there's a couple things to say about
that
first of all bloom wrote his work in the
80s
and it was getting a lot of traction in
the late 80s and the 90s and we read it
then
and the reaction of a lot of us was well
he's kind of right on some stuff but
he's kind of also an elitist prick on
other stuff as well
and man i'm glad i'm not i don't have
him as a professor
because what a stick in the mud this guy
is and that was back
so we're talking the 90s we're talking
about
30 years ago when i was an undergraduate
if you think that somehow out
alan bloom's closing of the american
mind is relevant today
uh to to present day circumstances
there's so much better stuff you could
you could be looking at i mean
you know read me neil postman's stuff
about technopoly that's that's
from around that same time but a bit a
lot more relevant i would say than
than the closing of the american mind i
guess they must be popular among
conservatives these days but it was it
was kind of a
halfway garbage book even back then um
bloom you know is is a good scholar when
it comes to like plato but when it came
to cultural politics
man that was an interesting one
so let's talk about the actual bone of
contention here which is
um yeah not only in previous videos
i haven't dismissed the the notion that
university faculty and admin are
disproportionately liberal left-wing
what i've said is that there's a lot of
[ __ ] involved in what people make of
that
so first off nobody can actually
generalize effectively about
the university system here in america
i've made this point
over and over and over again each
institution has its own
entity and you can't look at just voting
patterns or you know little polls or
stuff like that
to get your ideas about that you got to
actually spend some time on a university
campus
and not just you know they're looking
for for trouble
but actually spend some time uh in
classrooms and you know
walking around maybe like a couple years
or so or i don't know like like me like
20 years 30 years actually
and you'll find that even though there
is you know left
leaning you could say and and left and
liberal are not the same thing by the
way
um it doesn't really matter not in the
way that conservatives think that the
people who are select oh
i'm i'm gonna be brainwashed we're going
on campus that's such nonsense unless
you're at like
a really outlier school most of the time
we have a hard time getting the students
to even pay attention in class
let alone get you know uh whatever
propagandized by us
professors and if you go around and
actually talk with professors
you're going to find it out that they're
you know you
may a spouse left-leaning cause i mean
they're a leftist
that just means that that's that's what
they like and then watch their actual
behavior see what they donate money to
see what they donate time to a lot of
them are you know
not as left-leaning as you might think
so
you know this is this is one of those
bugaboo issues that keeps on coming up
over and over again from people on the
right who are
super concerned about you know
brainwashing in those institutions
you know unless you're in a place like
evergreen which is one out of you know
several thousand
colleges and universities it ain't
happening so
you know it's it's an interesting topic
but yeah
all right um let's see what else we got
here
a lot of back and forth from people
jeff asks any thoughts on finding a good
balance
keeping up with news given everything
going on recently i don't want to stop
looking entirely
but it's stressful and depressing
keeping up yeah yeah okay so that's a
great question
um yeah i would say
that um one thing you can do
is remind yourself that
you are not you know directly
responsible for all of this stuff you
don't actually have to take a stand on
it the world has been
screwed up again who's like studying
history and literature is very
useful the world has been screwed up in
multiple ways forever
as long as we've known it's just you're
getting this like
fire hose of news about the myriad
different ways in which it's screwed up
and the conflicting interpretations due
to social media the 24-hour news cycle
and the fact that we've blurred the
lines between news and opinion
so much and we've also eliminated a lot
of fact checkers as well
in the editorial and news processes
we do inhabit a different media
environment
but you can i mean one one option is to
like withdraw from it all together and
it would be
i think perfectly fine to take like
total days off
maybe it's helpful to
say one day a week say i'm not gonna
look at anything on my phone or on my
computer or on my tv or whatever it
happens to be
obviously don't pick a day where you're
stuck going to like medical appointments
and gotta watch the tv that's stuck in
the corner
uh jacked up to like 60 you know either
blaring some news channel or some
daytime talk show
but you know that i think that's
perfectly legitimate to say i'm going to
limit my
consumption of news and opinion stuff
um you might also so one one thing you
can do is kind of harden yourself
against it
and say none of this matters to me but
that's not really that productive now is
it
instead maybe it's better to practice um
some techniques you know and this is
where stoicism rightly understood
capital s stoicism not lower case
stoicism
that can be quite helpful because they
have a lot of techniques for dealing
with
what they call impressions or
appearances epictetus actually has an
entire chapter in the discourses on
on news that no news is actually good
news or bad news
so i think that could be quite helpful
for you
all right let me scroll back up here
since there's
a lot going on in in this
um
john says when i debate ethics with
people who haven't studied philosophy i
run into relative
relativity is there a convincing way to
refute naive moral relativism without
implying universals of some sort
no i mean and why shouldn't you have
universals of some sort
i mean we do have so we do have
universals
maybe they won't acknowledge it but too
bad for them i mean you don't have to
convince
everybody it's not your job to like
bring everybody around
i don't even try to convince everybody
in my classes you know i just say well
here's the positions and here's what's
problematic about them and let's see
what happens you know when we
we think this through would you want to
walk down a dark alley with a relativist
maybe that relativist over there but
what if you got a lot of money in your
your pocket and you know that they're
prone to like justifying anything that
they want to do or you think about
cases where people bring up relativism
it's usually because they're trying to
con you in some way or
justify their behavior or tear down the
moral system that
you're advocating but you you don't have
to be
concerned with that i mean unless you
take on yourself the
mantle of i'm the person arguing in
favor
of objective morality
and i notice that there's a response to
this saying
and one of the things somebody was
saying uh here we go gutter
ethics are not objective they are
subjective and intersubjective norms
decide what is accepted as ethical in a
culture but these norms get constantly
challenged by deviants
that's not what objective means
objective
you know could mean all sorts of
different things there's no one single
meaning of it but the fact that moral
norms get violated by people doesn't
mean that they're not objective
read some kant you know he talks about
that or bent them they all have
responses to
to that issue that's that's not that's
not the
the way to approach the thing now there
is certainly relativity right
of circumstance and there is
intersubjectivity which is which is
quite right
gooder is pointing out um to say that
ethics are
just subjective they're kind of crappy
ethics if that's the case
in that case we're using ethics as more
of a descriptive term the way like
nietzsche would talk about the ethic of
this or
you know weber would talk about you know
um the ethics you know the
protestant ethic you know but we got to
be careful when we're dealing with these
kind of slippery terms to distinguish
what meanings were
we're using they are ambiguous and
they're poly semis
all right so a lot of back and forth
here
i'm going to scroll down a bit bruno
asks any suggestion to someone who reads
a lot but struggles to move on to
writing
um oh that's that's a great question
kind of depends on the context of your
writing right if you're
uh so this is the bruno i'm thinking
about he's not a student
but somebody i think who would like to
do some writing you know
about philosophy or other issues but
let's
let's start with students students often
are kind of
stuck doing writing tasks that they
don't they don't often feel
confident about or up to so
one thing to begin with whatever you're
writing write the introduction last
don't worry about like
in this paper i will blah blah blah blah
blah or my argument
is this start writing stuff first and
then
worry about the organization and and
summarizing
after you've got some stuff down and you
know another thing that you can do and
this kind of applies universally is
you can make yourself write something
each day until you you get something
done
granted there may be days where you have
to take off or you're too busy
or things like that but you can make
yourself write
something even if it's garbage in your
own view
and you've at least written something
and you're building the habit of writing
right um husserl and a lot of the stuff
that hussville has to say is really
quite boring
hysterol had this thing every every
morning
it was either two or three hours he'd
sit down and write stuff
they got six i think it's like sixty
thousand pages in the historical
archives of these notes that he took
and these are in shorthand so you know
you can certainly get stuff done
if you decide when to do it but
um i mean the other thing to keep in
mind too is you might be
engaging in a bit of self-censoring
and perfectionism as you're writing it
getting stuff down is good
you can always go back you can always
edit
it's always better to have more than
less
even if the more is not that well put
together and clunky
you can improve it you can
send it around to other people and get
feedback but if you don't put something
down
then you've got you've got nothing to
work with right so
i don't know if that helps but hopefully
it does
all right uh
mark asks how am i doing and says hi to
everybody
so i'm doing pretty good i shot two core
concept videos this morning
and i've got them processing as we speak
doing a lot of class prep for my online
classes for the
the fall and we'll see i don't even know
if i have all my class assignments at
this
point but i'm building stuff out in the
class sites like
moodle and and uh blackboard
and uh what else uh moodle blackboard
um
schoology you know all those sorts of
things
so that's taking a good bit of time i've
been on this this uh
antibiotic doxycycline for the last week
and
man that's i forgot how rough that stuff
was
um i hate taking it i had to take it
twice when i had lyme's disease
and the first time i had to take it for
well both times i took it for a month
straight
and it was rough it makes you it
interferes with your digestive system so
i felt the first time like i had to
throw up all the time but i didn't uh
this time around it's like joint aches
and
my knees are constantly popping you know
worry some way when you're older
headaches all sorts of stuff like that
it's one of those like the
question is the cure worse than the
disease sort of things and then i found
out from some of my
you know uh current military uh
connections and friends that
they the military sometimes gives troops
doxycycline prophylactically
and just imagine having to march around
with a you know rucksack
and stuff like that man i wouldn't want
to do that on that
all right um let's see chris
says because of heidegger's emphasis on
language
is some sort of non-linguistic epiphany
about being impossible for him
um probably um
i mean it really depends on what you
mean by that vague phrase not you know
epiphany about being
which notice you've put into language um
heidegger's point is
is not that everything's language it's
that you can't get away from language
and things that are non-linguistic
are still brought into language i mean
consider the the you know seltzer can
right and imagine it didn't have all
those you know
logo stuff on it aha sparkling water
lime plus watermelon which i'll be
opening up before too long as my throat
gets a little dry
um just this by itself and the
experience of drinking it
those are non-linguistic right but they
can be
brought into the realm of language
that's that's part of heidegger's point
and they never fully get away from
language
even the possibilities of talking about
something non-linguistic
that's linguistic that's you're talking
about it in language
so um all right james
do i think that the capabilities
approach so we're talking about like
sen and and other uh people who are
looking at issues of how we distribute
things
um is a useful conceptual policy
framework when thinking about freedom or
poverty
yeah it certainly deserves a seat at the
table
um and it's interesting it doesn't get
taught all that often
i can't claim to be you know sort of
like expert level in that i mean i read
some of the literature and every once in
a while i'll teach some of it
but you know and i do a lot of teaching
and applied ethics
so you know business ethics is kind of a
standard class for me this this coming
fall i'm also teaching a
biomed ethics class and i also have
developed
you know professional ethics classes and
stuff like that and i don't see it
getting
used except in very
particular circumstances and
part of that you know could because
there's not
a lot of presentations that i've found
of it that aren't
referring to all sorts of other moral
theory and very jargony
uh and maybe you know i'm sure
somebody's written some good stuff about
it somewhere that's not that
way but i haven't found it yet then
again i haven't done a lot of looking
so you know maybe that's something to to
focus on
all right uh mark asks given his passing
this week
i'm interested in your thoughts on
stiegler are you familiar with any of
his philosophy
doesn't ring a bell um stiegler
uh death the first thing that comes up
so we're talking about bernard stiegler
um now i don't i don't think i know too
much about
about the guy looks like he founded a uh
a uh philosophy school and he's
interested in some people who i'm
interested in
and a lot of people i've never heard of
was imprisoned for a while at one time
so i
no i don't really have anything to say
about the guy unfortunately
um let's see
najib says i'm new to philosophy i
wanted to know philosophy has changed
your life or how you viewed life
uh yeah and and it's changed my life
after i started
studying philosophy you know as you
because you read other
philosophies sometimes you'll like
you know become a convert i've gone
through phases and you're like oh yeah
man that's that's really where it's at
i'm gonna
you know focus on that like i went
through a nature phase an assert
phase and a thomistic phase and a
derrida
phase and all that wittgenstein phase
and if you if you take it seriously it
should change your life
as a matter of fact that's one of the
problems with academic philosophy
is it gets done in this real vacuum even
when we teach
great thinkers like descartes i was
really surprised to find out
that quite a few people
when they teach descartes meditations
they only teach meditation one and two
and they don't teach like three through
six
and one and two are great but so are the
other ones
and and you know descartes is constantly
hammering
this has to do with how we live our life
this has to do with
where we place our commitments it's even
more clear in the discourse on method
but we teach descartes as if he's this
disembodied brain you know that has to
teach us about uh stuff like certainty
and doubt and had no interest in
actually how this would play out in life
and it's so artificial it's not even
it's not even true to descartes
himself you know and we do this with so
much other stuff so yeah when you when
you study philosophy if you're doing it
what i would say in a way that's
actually
connected with the rest of your life um
it should change your life
depending on what you're reading right
and
i also think you should read widely you
shouldn't just like find a thing that
confirms whatever temperament or
mindset you have this is what where a
lot of people i think go wrong with
stoicism
they're like oh i i read epictetus and
like it's totally what i'm all about man
well it might be it might not depends on
how you're reading them and you probably
should also read
other ancient philosophies so you've got
some points of comparison and you're not
just like
joining a club or something like that
all right matt has a good question here
i'm trying to start a youtube
or i'm not sure yty philosophy channel
i want to do more analysis not just
summary any advice how to balance rigor
and accessibility that is
that's the the golden question isn't it
how to balance
um being able to talk to ordinary people
in such a way that they
get something out of what you're saying
you don't have to be like you know uh
as relatable as as a comedian or
you know a motivational speaker or
something like that
how do you do that and also maintain
rigor so part of that i would say one of
the one of the keys to that
is not underrating your audience
and that means not listening to the
experts who are like
you've got to dumb everything down
because the ordinary person
just isn't able to get it now it could
be that your approach or style or
something like that
needs to be simplified in certain
respects but you don't want to simplify
it too much
you want people to be able to have
something meaty
to bite into to digest and come back for
right and so if you you know like if
you're shooting a video
and your audience is watching it they
don't have to get
every single thing out of that video the
first time they can come back and
rewatch it that's the cool thing about
having videos isn't it
same thing with podcasts same thing with
writing too
so i would say there's that don't
underrate your audience
um speak about the stuff that you
you're interested in that you care about
that you think is worth
thinking through and try to do it in
such a way that that people can relate
to it
use plenty of examples you know this is
a great pedagogy by the way
aristotle talks about that cicero talks
about that anselm of canterbury was
known
for his many use of simultutinase that
is examples or
or likenesses um
so those are those are things that could
be helpful
you probably want to run it past some
some other people it's always good to
get other eyes
on your material so you may think that
what you're doing is very accessible
but maybe it isn't you know maybe you
need somebody to say
well here's here's where i would tweak
this a bit or here's where i would
try not try to talk about all this at
once and
you know the videos that i've had that
have been
most helpful for teaching people are
these core concept videos
uh anywhere from 10 to 25 minutes
by the way don't believe the experts who
are like it all has to be in five
minutes because the audience can't watch
any longer that's all [ __ ]
educational experts boomers all came up
with that
in the uh early 2000s and it stuck and
people keep believing it
but it's not true at all people will
watch a 20-minute video
if it's got compelling content all the
way through and re-watch it
so yeah i think those are off the cuff
the only
useful bits of advice i can i can come
up with
but um hope that helps
all right uh
william zen any thoughts on thomas
sowell is he worth
reading seriously he's worth giving a
first read to i would say
i'd i've never found much in sowell that
i thought was
particularly uh interesting
or or worth going back to because i've
read you know
quite a few of his his works um
he seems just kind of like a you know
sour guy
um it gets used a lot but it may
uh have some things that they think are
useful in his his ideas
but he's one of those thinkers where
sort of like ein rand right
there's nothing wrong with actually
reading rand it's not going to like
destroy your brain unless you're one of
these gullible types who
automatically believes whatever you said
la whatever you read last is true
and there's some things that she has to
say that are quite good but
they're found in other people and then
the stuff that's like distinctively rand
tends to be kind of noxious so you're
like well you know
hierarchy of values discussion great
that rand brings that up
and at different places in the uh
virtue of selfishness but you can also
get it from mock shaler and get it
without
all of these other things in the
background
all right lyndon asks what does mcintyre
disagree with hume about well
to start with something that not only
mcintyre disagrees with him but
so does so many other people and hume
when read
rightly right the reason could only be
the slave of the passions
not quite true even in hume hume is uh
you know being hyperbolic at that point
but there are there were a lot of people
and you know it's interesting so let me
tell you a little bit about mcintyre
one of his his ideas he likes to always
do
you know three different versions of
things and have them talking to each
other three traditions
so in the seminar that i was in with
mcintyre in the
last faculty erasmus institute seminar
at notre dame this would be like 2005 i
think
um he and this is part of the reason why
i got into that that and the fact that
he wanted to ask me about prison
teaching because i was one of the most
junior faculty
he had three things one was aristotelian
tomism
big surprise you know another was freud
and lecant which is quite interesting so
the psychoanalytic
stuff and he also brought in melanie
klein and winnicott and people like that
and then it was rational choice theory
and
mcintyre's presentation of that began
actually with hobbes and hume because
there's a certain sort of
mentality about reason and the passions
and desires and stuff like that that
runs through
rational choice or decision theory
however you want to talk about it
and uh you know he he brought all three
of these into connection with each other
and um so that that's that's one of the
things actually mcintyre has a whole
book on him
uh ethical writings
worth checking out um but you'll find
you know a lot of discussion of hume and
who's justice which rationality
and summon after virtue and coming up
in other places christopher anadale good
friend and colleague of mine from
i don't know how long ago uh chris and i
have known each other
since being together at some conference
and i don't remember exactly which one
it was
i want to say going back like
almost 20 years we might have still both
been in grad school at the time so
chris says mcintyre is an inspiration he
is yeah mcintyre is a really cool guy
um he's the kind of guy except for his
sentence structure everybody
dislikes that where you read his stuff
and you're like man i wish i'd written
that
i i couldn't have but and i'm glad that
somebody did
this is what aristotle by the way calls
emulation
in rhetoric uh book two his analysis of
the passions
this feeling of pain or discomfort that
you have
at seeing what somebody else is able to
accomplish
not because you're envious of them and
want to bring them down but because that
you recognize that they're so far
beyond your capacities and you feel kind
of kind of
rough about that mcintyre gives me that
so all right uh lechomir do i plan any
new episodes in the self-studies
series in the near future yeah i do i'm
gonna try to get to augustine this month
i've just been like super busy over the
summer
i've taught four uh online classes
after coming off of a semester of
teaching i don't know if i taught five
or six
classes last semester and i've i've
surprisingly
without doing any marketing had a lot
more tutorial and philosophical client
counseling clients come my way so it's
it's just been a very busy
uh summer so far and i haven't gotten to
those but i'm hoping by the end of the
month
to have an augustine one out and then i
want to do boethius next
and probably aquinas and then i'll
jump into some modern thinkers all right
uh call me shibboleth um why
should one pick schopenhauer over hegel
i don't know why you have to pick one
over the other
um oh you know and and if you
if you're gonna like say well which one
of these has reality right i wouldn't
pick either one you know
i would probably uh there's a lot of
other thinkers i would probably go with
instead
that's it i love schopenhauer i love
reading him he's fun to read
and i i do i i don't enjoy reading hegel
that much but i think hegel's very
important
um i don't know why we have to choose
between
the two of those uh barklord says happy
birthday yeah it's coming up
so 10 days today is the eighth it's
coming up the 18th
i'm gonna have a i should mention this
i'm gonna have a birthday bash
online on the i think it's the 16th
because you know we're having the
democratic national convention here in
milwaukee and granted joe biden isn't
going to be here
but it's happening a block not even a
block from our apartment
and so we're anticipating there might be
a lot more web traffic
it might be difficult to hold the online
event so we're doing an
online event for that because it's my
50th birthday so
i'll do a little you know jibber jabber
here about
uh what it's like to be 50 and you know
whatever else i want to talk about and
then i'll like do something sort of like
this where we're doing
q a and comments and stuff and we'll do
a toast
i'll have some beer you'll have whatever
you want on your end and we'll do a
toast and that'll be kind of kind of fun
all right zen
uh any tips on how to make reading
regularly a habit for my children oh
that's a tough one especially since i
got one kid
who says they don't want to read
much because they they're stuck doing it
in school and i was like
let's uh break it into two things you
got the stuff you're gonna read for
school
and that's your assigned work and then
let's have like pleasure reading the
stuff you do for fun
instead of it being like all reading is
a chore
uh because people are making me do this
um let's find some stuff that you like
over here
and then i even went so far as to say
you know when i was in school
um i often didn't read the stuff i was
supposed to i read whatever the hell i
wanted to
and i would smuggle in books into the
class
and read the books i wanted to read
usually sci-fi and fantasy
instead of the assigned work that we
were talking about that day
maybe i'm not a good parent for for
saying that but
it might help you know so i i don't know
i think there's there's
um there's something that you got to
find some hook
that gets that kid into reading
um and i think you know it's here i'm
going to see him really old school and
curmudgeonly
you do want to have books in the
person's hand right
uh not just a kindle not just a
phone not just reading in electronic
formats but
actually holding a book and turning the
pages because we know that
you do read differently in that way
not drastically differently but it's
it's good to get
in the habit of actually reading and
carrying around books
all right andrew is there a
philosophical thought that connects or
interlinks most if not all philosophical
schools
that's a tough one is there a
a an idea that connects all
or most of the schools i mean you can
say that there's certain basic
issues that most philosophical schools
traditionally have to engage in when we
kind of differentiate philosophy
into fields along those lines like
metaphysics you gotta have
some understanding of what reality is
what the difference is between
you know appearance and reality some
some speculation about
space and time uh causality
you know and then there's ethics and we
can talk about epistemology maybe
aesthetics
but particular thoughts that run through
them i don't know
i mean aristotle wanted to say things
like certain basic logical
axioms are inescapable because
you know if you try to deny them you you
would end up using them
but that's so formal and content-less
that
i don't know that that helps very much
so um yeah that's that's actually
that's a tough question
all right um
the mgs 501 could i explain about
metaphysics of presence that's sort of a
catch phrase that
uh deconstructionists use um
talking about treating things as if they
are
just present and focusing on that
a thing called metaphysics of presence
out there
all right um the [ __ ]
54538 thoughts on the new trend of
speculative
realism i just jumped for a second
let me scroll back um
where was that also the reductive
materialism is not opposed to emergency
deluge or emmanuel
delanda i don't read to lose as a
reductive materialist so that's that's
kind of a non-starter there but i mean i
guess it depends entirely
on what you mean by reductive
materialism right um
deluge is a weird wild thinker who has
all sorts of room for stuff i mean if
we're going to say that the lose
is a materialist and you know has room
for emergence we
talk about you know santiana and james
and people like that as well but
um it all depends again on how we're
using the term so speculative realism
um i'm drawing a blank on what that's
what we're associating that with
whenever we have isms
you know we often are using them as
shorthand uh
for other stuff
okay so we're talking about the object
oriented
uh people right um it's
it's okay it's interesting um
i mean i've actually met and interacted
with harman
and i'm kind of puzzled about how you
know
why this is so important
um but yeah so i don't have much to say
about that
all right um mark
is there some way to work against this
notion of post-truth in our popular
media and political discussion
well i don't see post truth is that big
of an idea in
popular media and political discussion i
see
a lot of people talking about truth and
a lot of people carrying on just like
ordinary
partisanship i mean this notion that you
would like
say that your opponents are sofists or
something like that that's not a new
thing
you know um the notion that that you
would say oh
you know nobody really knows except for
my side well that's been going on since
the enlightenment
i don't see that as as something
radically new in our our
issue all right uh t t
y k says if you read wendell berry
there's some interesting parallels
between him and macintyre
i have not read wendell berry i've one
actually i i take that back i've read
like one or two essays here and there
and i don't remember anything from them
other than the guy really likes farming
a lot
people have talked about him a lot and
recommended him to me a lot but i've
just never
gotten into him and it's not anything
about like
you know whether i think he's good or
not there's there's a lot of people who
have been recommended and just
never get around to to reading um so i
got to take your word that there's a lot
of connections with mcintyre
uh autodidact any tips on how to write
notes on philosophy i'm a terrible
person to ask about that because a lot
of times i don't take notes
as a matter of fact when i was an
undergraduate i almost never took notes
i started taking notes when i was in
grad school
and i've got like
stacks of notebooks that i've never gone
back to and looked over again
it was just sort of like something for
me to do at the time so
i'm not somebody who really relies
heavily on
on notes and i just kind of
store it all up here it's probably not
that great of an idea as i get older
but um yeah
it's better to ask other people who
make use of notes extensively for
organizing their thoughts
all right uh dimitri am i interested in
philosophy expressed in novels or
fiction could return to dialogues be
useful
yeah i'm very interested in fiction
that's why i did the whole worlds of
speculative fiction series
each one of those authors we explore
philosophical themes
in their their novels or short stories
um you know some of the people that are
in that series are among my favorite
authors like philip k
dick for example who has his characters
talking philosophy
often quite explicitly in the novels
dostoevsky's another
great example of a philosophical
novelist
um uh dennis dieterow
you know another great example as well
actually mary wollstonecraft i don't
know if you know this didn't just write
the vindication of the rights of women
she actually wrote several novels
sort of dramatizing the key themes that
she was working with
so yeah there's sorts of you know
opportunities for doing um
some of the other people in the
existentialist
movement you know use novels uh
rilka is a prime example right um kafka
of course
uh sartre and de bouvoir and camus
and marcel wrote plays
you know marcelro plays rather than
novels but it's still the same sort of
thing marcel actually thought that
the dramatic situation is is very
important to philosophy
so yeah uh andrew do you think our human
condition for
meaning and purpose is a flaw or a
blessing i mean it's both
right um according to nietzsche
he might be right about this it could be
that
it's just some weird quirk of
of our evolution our design that we
are so hungry for meaning that we're
willing to
falsify most of our experience and you
know consolidate it into things
i mean it is definitely part of the
human condition
um what would be the alternative
being just like animals i mean even
animals
nowadays i'm looking at my cat right
over there
they've had so much interaction with us
that
they don't like seek meaning or anything
but they seek they definitely have a
rich
world that they live in because of that
um
so i you know i just look at that as
part of the
kind of thing that we are is rational
animals
and it's very complex we don't really
know
completely what it means to be a
rational animal i mean we can easily
come up with a definition but it always
gets more and more tangled
by the way mcintyre somebody who's like
plumbing that
independent rational animals right that
book
all right um
bark lord points out and i had an intro
to philosophy instructor at community
college who's a right-wing libertarian a
randian
i had one who was a colleague when i was
at marist
uh jurgen whatever his name was was was
a
hardcore randian he also did stuff on
aristotle because
no surprise rand likes aristotle um
you can find plenty of conservatives in
philosophy departments
and in other other departments as well
you just gotta get a look
you know every like i said every college
every university is its own
environment same thing by the way goes
for corporate america
you know you can look around and one
company may have
this kind of culture and another country
company has this kind of culture and
you know the management can vary
considerably
uh tashi and asks a simple but hard
question how are how
am i well i mentioned earlier coming off
of a
round of doxy cycling which left me left
me kind of worn out
loopy and with joint aches but i'm glad
i'm almost done with that
i'll be able to start taking walks again
soon you know
i'm uh turning 50 this month and that's
uh
kind of an interesting thing my oldest
kid is is
starting college up here at the end of
this month that's a trip too
our cat is almost 18 years old you know
and uh there's all sorts of stuff going
on you know
so that's that's uh something we could
certainly say
all right peter schwartz since natural
sciences have broken off and may answer
many of the metaphysical problems of
philosophy do you think that modern
philosophy
should focus on ethics religion etc
what's left
i mean philosophy this is not a new
thing
the modern sciences the more that they
approach their ground
issues of the more reflexive they get
about their own involvement the more
they involve philosophy of science and
epistemology and ethics and all these
other
things it's not so simple as like well
here's a dividing line
and you know now the psychologists own
all this
that's nonsense the psychologists half
the time don't even know the history of
their own discipline
and they're arguing with each other
about you know all sorts of stuff back
and forth
that having a philosopher in there can
can help with
actually i think this is a this is a
great time to be a philosopher
because you get to like be almost you
know parasitically stuck into all these
other fields
including you know stuff outside of the
sciences and the whole business world
i'm doing a a a presentation
just this coming uh next month
for an online conference i got asked to
step in and help somebody out of
ethics for paralegals and i'm talking
about applying stoic philosophy to deal
with
stress you know we get to be real great
multi-disciplinary
people if if we if we want to in
philosophy
so i like them too they're they're
they're fun you know
um oops got an unstable connection not
sure
what's going on there we go hopefully
we're we're all the way
back i think we had a flux in the
internet
what is uh so here's from n1colp
lp what is heidegger's critique to the
analytic tradition
i don't know that heidegger has a
critique
solely to the analytic tradition
but you can say that heidegger's
approach
could be applied to various movements
within the analytic tradition there is
no analytic tradition by the way there's
analytic traditions
which interweave with each other sort of
like a braid
because you know the ordinary language
philosophy is as different from
russell's
uh you know logistics project as it is
from
some of the stuff that's going on today
it's interesting you know that a lot of
people over time have taken like this
one thing to be analytic philosophy or
this one thing
and i mean heidegger's critique would be
similar to that given against
earlier modes of philosophy namely
that um what they're doing is truncating
philosophy down to what's much more
manageable for them
and thereby losing sight of the larger
project or picture and they're doing so
because that's you know what's
comfortable for them but then there's a
loss of authenticity and
you know um i think that'd be a fair
criticism
all right um
could i do some videos on structuralism
and post structuralism i'd love to see a
video on roland barter claude levy
strauss
i do videos primarily on what i'm
teaching in my classes i do have two
foucault videos that
i'm going to be bringing out before too
long once i'm done you know releasing
the hume ones that i shot from my
students this summer but generally the
core concept videos are stuff that i'm
shooting
for the classes that i'm teaching and
i'm not teaching a lot of that that
you know uh cutting edge continental
stuff because i'm teaching
you know basic things to to students i
don't think it's it's usually very
helpful to like throw some
you know bart in somebody's lap and say
there you go
let's let's go at it you know um and
levy strauss i mean i don't
anticipate you know unless somebody
commissions me to shoot videos on levy
straps i don't find him that
that interesting bart is but bart is
kind of tough for
my typical students to get and you know
if i teach an aesthetics class or a
semiotics class maybe i would do it but
i don't know um
i'd be more likely to shoot videos on
foucault
and maybe down the line on some
accessible things that deleuze has
written
certainly not going to be doing
anti-oedipus for undergrads
uh but you know maybe stuff from
critique essays critique
the clinic or you know logic of sense um
i don't know we'll we'll see um
but right now i'm i'm actually trying to
fill in gaps
that have been left open for quite a
while you know like hume's
inquiry concerning human understanding
that's an important one
i gotta get to that right um
all right tom do i think intelligence is
a force of nature like
gravity i'm not even sure how i would
draw the analogy
with that so
uh tashin says a professor in my country
who specializes in hustle called him a
rationalist in the seminar which felt
off because i'd considered him a rash
radical empiricist he was talking about
early hustle two your take
both um it depends on what you mean by
rationalists that term has been used in
so many different ways
i would ask for clarification from your
your professor
phenomenology does have some rationalist
elements to it
it also has some empiricist elements i
don't view by
i mean lock is a great example too lock
is is
a empiricist who has lots and lots of
rationalist elements to his
his work you know um bushfield by the
way
is is quite interested in hume and takes
the you know notion of association of
ideas
from him plays a big role in uh
the passive synthesis lectures
all right um bailin asks what do you
make of the increasing number of young
men disconnecting from modern life and
becoming
neets um i don't know that that's
actually the case
i'm going to actually have to look up
what neets
means uh not in education employment
or training okay so dropping it right
um i guess it's cool if you can
it's sort of like what you call good
work if you can get it if you can
actually
live a life where you aren't starving
or dying of exposure which means
somebody's putting you
putting you up somewhere and you're not
working you're not you know
engaging in education or training um
if that is the case then maybe we're
going
into a new era we're going to have a
massive problem and it's not just going
to be young men
in the next 20 30 years as automation
ai logistics gets more and more complex
i think we can look forward to seeing
way more unemployment than we're used to
and we're going to have to figure out
what to do with all these people what
are they going to do all day
when there literally aren't jobs for
them this is something that we've talked
about before
a bit you know the the post-job
future it's not as if jobs are never all
there all the jobs are going to go away
and we're going to post scarcity future
but
um we're going to have to figure out
what to do and i don't see a lot of
industry leaders or people talking about
that
all right uh aqib i'm a beginner when it
comes to philosophy what are some good
introductory books you'd recommend to
someone who doesn't know anything about
philosophy outside of wikipedia articles
i don't know i mean i i don't usually
give people introductory books
um i say start with plato
you know there's nothing keeping you
from reading the dialogues you don't
have to try to understand them all at
once
but why why start out with somebody
else's
pre-digested schema why not get into the
primary texts
you know you might get hit by a bus
tomorrow wouldn't it be nice to have
read
some original texts
um all right
william asks is there in your view a
viable foundation for absolute
universal immutable moral facts in the
absence of god or a creator
designer of the cosmos and its
inhabitants if so is a consequentialist
i don't know i never think about
things that way so that's that's not
something i usually give a lot of
thought to
um
sort of like saying is there this thing
and by the way is it red
um i don't know
i don't have to just pump that one uh
all right gutter says i had lyme's
disease couldn't move my neck it was
stuck
man it'll mess you up uh and yeah mike i
already know about eating yogurt
um i've been taking antibiotics you know
off and on for quite a while uh percival
first time to ask in an ama do you have
any advice to a 20 year old who is
thinking whether to start a relationship
or not
not really because i don't know your
case and i don't know your situation
um and i don't know who you're thinking
about starting a relationship with
so all of those factors would have to
come into play all right i'd have to
know something
about what what the situation is but
uh i'll just give sort of a general bit
of advice
if i were to like think about my own 20
year old self or i'm thinking about the
advice that i'll give to my kids as they
go into their 20s
don't expect those relationships to be
the the one the final relationship
you know um a lot of times sometimes
people meet somebody that way i mean i
i met the person who's my wife back when
she was 14 and i was 15 and
um but if we'd gotten together at that
time man what what a mess that would
have been or if we'd gotten together in
our 20s
that probably would have been a mess as
well because we were unformed
you know actually there is one really
great bit of advice that you might want
to read on this
uh it comes from rilka's letters to a
young poet
it's either in letter seven or letter
eight and he talks about
young people who haven't fully formed
themselves wanting to like
fuse together and give each other
everything but they
they they're they don't really have
their act together and so what they do
is they you know they hook up and it
turns into
a mess because neither one really has uh
what they need
for the other and he defines love
as two solitudes bordering and
protecting each other
you have to develop that aspect of
solitude first
all right
tommaso what is it for two things to be
distinct rather than parts of a single
thing
as in if holes are beyond parts what
makes holes separate to each other
i guess not being the same thing as it
seems i'm not sure i quite understand
your your question so what makes this
different from this you know or
my head different from this uh
can play instant i i'm not sure i i get
what you're asking there
all right uh isaac what advice do you
have for reading aristotle despite the
writing is straightforward i find myself
reading certain passages over and over
again
you're doing the right thing you should
read certain passages over and over
again i mean i've been reading certain
passages
over and over again in aristotle in
english
since 1990 and in greek
since uh around uh 97 98
so you know uh that's the way it works
in philosophy you read certain passages
over and over again
because philosophy is uh
complex and difficult and and same thing
applies to
reading history and reading um
literature you you should be reading the
stuff over and over again
because oftentimes you'll see new
associations or
things that you missed i i read
descartes meditations whether i'm
teaching it or not
in french and in latin every year at
least once a year
and every time i'm like oh wow there was
this going on that i missed i read
plato's
uh symposium uh every year and find
additional things that i missed
that's okay that's that's par for the
course you're doing fine if that's the
case
i you might also want to take a look at
the self-directed study video on on
aristotle
all right from love yourself i saw you
live just now because i started on your
series on hegel to help me better
understand his works
i wanted to show some appreciation for
the work you've been doing on this book
yeah yeah it's
it's it's been quite a ride the half
hour hegel series
um had i known how much work it was
going to be
maybe i wouldn't have committed to doing
it but but there it is and i keep on
churning away
hopefully this month i can get back up
to my six videos a month
and that would be quite nice to be able
to do
so we'll see if that that happens and i
want to get done with it eventually i
have actually applied that same
close reading of the text and then
commentary on it with uh videos on
epictetus's and caridian as well
and i'm going to do that i'm hoping
maybe this fall to do that
with uh anselm's proselogian and then
i'm going to do it with the cart's
meditations
using the in that case the the latin
french and english
text and then and then commenting on it
so
all right uh lokesh what do you think
about the british idealist like fh
bradley also i'm not able to comprehend
hegel's view on history
well uh you know there's more than one
hegel's view on history you might want
to break it down into its parts and see
what parts you can understand
and i would say the place that you want
to go for that is the lectures on the
philosophy of history right
not the phenomenology but but the stuff
where he's actually talking to students
about that that sort of thing
um bradley you know green they're
interesting people to read
you can kind of get the idea so analytic
philosophy
in its in its origins if we're talking
about the british
uh part and not the the german stuff
is in part a reaction against that
british
idealism or hegelianism of the time
and so it's kind of interesting to to
think about that isn't it
um what's what's actually happening
there if you read their stuff it's often
quite interesting but there's a lot of
places
it's been a while since i've read any of
those guys where you're like
what what are they talking about this is
really it sounds great
it's really quite vague though what's
what's happening here
so all right uh
let me scroll down a bit
yet still yet and still we rise is it
fair to say that there's a mental
illness epidemic going
on uh i don't know that there's an
epidemic
um that would imply that it's being like
caught from one person to another i mean
we could say that there's a lot of
cases of mental illness but you know we
also want to like
differentiate between different sorts of
mental illness and we want to think
about like how much of it is due to
diagnosis that wasn't happening in the
past so
here's a prime example on my mother's
side of the family
my adopted mother's side there is a lot
of bipolar disorder
quite a few of my cousins have struggled
with it and one of my uncles
um actually ruined his life you know
he uh he was diet he didn't make it
through high school because he was
viewed as just being a bad kid
essentially got kicked out joined the
air force um
worked in in there for quite a while got
out
got married was actually living
um with his wife you know
right next door i think to my mom and
dad in madison
they they had a a daughter uh amy joy
who was born
three days before me and we used to
always be hanging out together they used
to call us day and night
because i was bald and very pale and she
was she had dark hair and was was quite
tan and he lost his marriage because of
it
you know he he ended up having a
breakdown
hiding in a cupboard his wife left took
his kid
he didn't see her for years and years
and years uh
he he ended up you know moving to
indiana with my grandpa and grandma
and living in the basement and being a
wood carver for a long time a very
great gentle man who taught me how to
carve
um and then he had another breakdown and
he was
stuck in that room only coming out at
night to get food for
for five years wouldn't participate in
anything
and i mean that was none of that was
understood as mental
illness back then and and you know once
we were able to actually
get him to a psychiatrist and and get a
diagnosis and get the sort of things
that he needed in order to function
which turned out to be a whole battery
of different uh
chemicals some of which would wear off
after a while
once he had that he could he could have
a life back again
i don't know that there's more mental
illness now than there was
in the past i think in a lot of cases we
just didn't identify it properly and we
we identified all those moral failures
or
something else all right
uh glacier do i have an opinion on
isaiah berlin and hannah rent's
relationship with heidegger
i don't have much of an opinion on
berlin i mean i read his stuff but i
don't really
care particularly about him one way or
the other
how to rent a relationship with
heidegger i mean she was a student he
was a professor
these sort of things happen a lot of the
time he apparently was quite a
charismatic guy
clearly i think if she had known what he
was going to turn into
she wouldn't have been as into him
but we don't always know these sorts of
things all right
um oh chris chris says it was the
wesleyan
philosophical society that we met at
that's interesting
so that was the wesleyan philosophical
society
is is uh sort of like the you know uh
american catholic philosophical
association or the
society of christian philosophers but
it's for wesleyan
that is holiness uh denominations the
methodists
church of the nazarene you know some of
the other ones and it was held
at a place that was important to my
family one of my
great uncles was was a viatorian i
almost said vincentians but that's not
right
viatorian and um the college
that's now all of it nazarene that was
bought entirely from the viatorians
uh when they when they sold it and my
uncle who is kind of a holy terror in
the order at that time
uh father art lamrys he
actually was one of the people who who
worked there and so
so yeah i guess that must be where chris
and i met
uh and then you know we chatted about
different stuff and and
we've been running across each other at
conferences
ever since then i'm gonna say another
thing too about christopher anadale
so a lot of you know me because of my
video work right
so there are very few other academics
who are
interested in producing lecture videos
for their students that can be viewed by
other people
chris is somebody who has been doing
that now for
years and his videos are very good um
that that question that somebody had
about accessibility and rigor he's
balancing those
in his videos and so um i would
definitely
check him out um easy enough to find
anna dale a-n-a-d-a-l-e
see him here in the chat stream all
right
um santa those has a question about
speculative fiction here theoretically
how would i go about
inquiring about rights to write a novel
about
cain in the cane universe as a foreigner
who has the rights now that carl e
wagner died
i don't know that's a great question i
don't know who has the rights
um i think there's two things you could
do
one would be just to write it as fan
fiction right and i don't think you
would need to get any sort of
special rights to do that there's all
sorts of websites you could post it on
and if you if you're saying it's just
fan fiction what are they going to do to
you like give you a takedown order or
something like that i'm willing to bet
there's probably all sorts of fan
fiction cane novels out there
you wanted to publish a king novel
yeah then because the character is is
part of their schtick you've got to find
out who actually
owns the rights and i don't know who
owns it um but it's a great question
all right um
gene or john baez can i briefly explain
what epictetus means on judging people's
character on the basis of where they put
their self-interest
external versus moral choice is this a
good way to do it okay so
it's not where they put their
self-interest it's where they it's where
they apply themselves right it's what
they make important to themselves
uh external things which are
indifference or their own
core they're they're maybe translators
moral choice the greek is pro-racist
which we also translate as moral uh
moral principle um
faculty of choice will so it's a
question
about whether you're trying to pursue
external goods or whether you're
focusing more on on what's within
okay this is really basic i mean
socrates
uh was constantly telling people they
ought to focus less
on um their reputation or money or stuff
like that or even their bodies and more
on their
their soul so uh now you could focus in
the wrong ways you could be like i want
to be the biggest bastard ever okay
that's not a great way to focus
internally
but for the most part that would that
would be good
um i just skipped a bit
let me scroll back up uh
thanks jimmy there's there's a cartoon
of a some sort of lemon head giving a
oh it's a present to to somebody that's
very nice
all right let me see where were we
uh hakeetas quidditas what's the best
book to read on wittgenstein's views on
religion
i don't know you know i haven't been
doing
any real work on wittgenstein since grad
school so
i'm sure there's probably some new stuff
out there that's pretty good
uh justice smooth what are your thoughts
on herbert marcuza i'm considering
reading his heideggerian marxism book
so whenever you're going to read marcusa
settle in for a wild ride
right that's what i would say marcusa is
probably
you know he's probably been the most
successful person in the frogfit school
because the hippies took him up
and uh he does have some really
interesting things to say but you gotta
you gotta do some work and puzzling it
out
all right um let's see here
jimmy says an early happy birthday to me
thanks that's very
very nice uh francisco
says in judaism there's the notion of
the messiah would it
be too ambitious to develop a new theory
of ethics
and of aesthetics that describes its
what and how and its danger of this
messianic figure
um i i don't really understand the
question you
you just want to develop a new theory of
ethics criticizing
jewish anticipation of the messiah um
i don't know that that's really
worth doing but all right
uh beerson are you the most
knowledgeable content creator on youtube
ever probably not
um i'm willing to bet
there's plenty of people more
knowledgeable than me
um jessa smoot what do you think of
freud's death drive
if you mean like as an idea that there
is something
like a death drive i don't know that
i would describe it exactly as such i
mean
this brings me back to thinking about
philip k dick right it's interesting
because
dick speculates about this but not so
much
just in terms of the death drive but
like original sin
and uh you know basic drive to breaking
things down i think there might be
something
like that going on
but it depends on how we construe it you
know that's that's the key
thing the galactic nomad have i read
bengali
literature i have not so
uh not much to say there um
chris meyer plultinus worth spending
time there what's
your view of these so-called neoplatonus
i don't i don't know why you'd say call
them so-called um they are neoplatonists
and uh i like neoplatonists i platinus
is definitely worth reading so
so are some of the lesser known ones
like alchemists right
and so are the middle platoonists uh the
platonus tradition is really quite
quite worth engaging it's it's very
interesting what they're they're doing
and they're
uh you know examination and adaptation
of of plato's texts
so all right
uh
signats what do you think of the
pentagon's admission in new york times
articles on ufos or uaps and the
philosophical implications
assuming there's some credibility to it
that's a big assumption right i don't
know i haven't been following that
um i've i've always thought it'd be
pretty cool if there was alien life
provided they're not go like you know
independence day yes right
um but uh i don't know i haven't i
haven't been following that at all
ivan says uh hi from russia thanks a lot
for
religious religious studies i've been
friends with a bunch of evangelical
missionaries here
i learned a lot about them from your
lectures where else can i read about
them
i'm not sure how you'd learn about a lot
about evangelical missionaries from my
lectures maybe you're thinking of
the class that i taught a long time ago
and you know recorded
videos from the classes the religion in
american culture
there weren't that many videos on them
um where can you read about evangelicals
i mean there's like a host of literature
i wouldn't know where to start with that
pal says i really did not enjoy
philosophy in college i felt like it had
mostly to do with my professor
he had a lot of issues trying to explain
certain passages
still don't understand the republic well
yeah that's that that can be a problem
um a lot of times philosophy professors
manage to turn
off undergraduate students from
philosophy i actually did a
a doctor was a dr sandler soapbox
thing about uh those sorts of classes
saying
intro classes are the most important
classes we ever teach we need to you
know step up our
game in teaching them because that's the
one time when we can like turn people on
to philosophy
so but you could you can study the
republic on your own and understand it
and you don't have to understand
all of it you know but uh you can
keep um grinding away at it
mcghool says uh good morning from the
philippines
i'd like to ask which philosopher did
descartes read to believe god's
existence
um i don't think that descartes read a
philosopher to believe god's existence i
think
descartes provides you with some
interesting arguments for god's
existence
that bear some similarity to previous
proofs but also
are kind of their own thing you know uh
the
the uh argument and meditation three
is it a is it a cosmological argument is
it an argument from intelligence what
what's going on there
um it i when i teach philosophy of
religion i actually teach it is like its
own
genre of argument um
so i wouldn't i wouldn't try to look for
roots
of of descartes and his uh
arguments for the existence of god and
other people's thoughts
um lord roku have i read the day cons
constantia from uh ellipsis who started
the neostosism movement
i wouldn't say started the neostosis
movement it was kind of a thing that was
going on
uh if if if you did what are your
thoughts on it i mean all those
neostokes are kind of interesting
they have to try to it's interesting to
see them take
you know this inheritance of stoicism
and reread it and then try to bring it
into
a christian framework which by the way
so is descartes doing
the card has a lot of stoic aspects to
his work
all right um
bozo why do continental philosophers
often write in this very cryptic and
esoteric style
i do think some philosophers can pull
that out
um well some continental philosophers do
and some continental philosophers don't
you know heidegger is is not writing in
a cryptic style heidegger is trying to
forge
new language for what he's trying to
communicate
um dairy does more of a let's play
around with words and sometimes dairy
die is very rigorous and sometimes dairy
does just kind of a show-off jerk you
know
um so it varies considerably
i would say a lot of their their
hang-arounds kind of like
got the shtick and then they would use
all this jargon that when you pull it
apart you're like there's nothing here
you know
but i wouldn't say that's the case
universally with continental thinkers
um i i you know continental philosophy
comprises a lot of different traditions
it's not as if there's one thing
called continental philosophy
uh sorry i'm human what what do you
think of spinoza how should i go about
understanding his philosophy
spinoza is okay you know he's not my
favorite i
i always found him interesting um
i would say that you know you can read
start out by reading the principles of
cartesian philosophy because that shows
like in
early on trying to work with stuff
obviously the big work is the ethics but
the teological political uh tractatus
for treaties
is also quite interesting and important
a good bit of that is
regurgitating hobbs on some issues but
um
some of it's some of it's quite
interesting um
so what you know how should i go about
um
understanding his philosophy well
you know get used to the more
geometrical you know
the weird way of presenting things that
he uses in the ethics
um and you know he's uh
as a follow-up question do i ever think
i'll cover spinoza on your channel yeah
eventually
i mean it depends on what i teach i
don't usually teach spinoza very often
in my classes so
uh and it's not because he's not worth
teaching it's just there's so much other
stuff that's
i feel more worth teaching so
all right um
we got about uh
13 minutes here so i'm going to scroll
down just to see how many more questions
there
are and then i'm going to start picking
out some things that are easy
to do easy to answer um
so i'm going to start going kind of a
bit at random
uh k howard are you am i still gonna do
my speculative fiction video on jg
ballard
uh maybe eventually you know it depends
on how long we remain in pandemic
mode uh and and can't meet at libraries
i've already got the stuff picked out
for the the fall because i'm going to be
really
super busy so i'm not i'm not really
taking on
new authors who i haven't read much
before i've read crash and that's about
it
um so like this this coming month
actually uh it's coming up two weeks
from now
doing uh walter miller so canticle uh
for leibowitz and his follow-up the
saint liberts and the wild horse woman
i'm gonna do some echo
gonna do some uh scott our scott backer
so ballard would probably be next year
if i if i'm gonna do it
um let me scroll around a bit
diogenes the cynic is kojov a good
resource for hegel i know it's probably
just a basic question but i just ordered
it
um depends on what you mean by a good
resource if you want a really
interesting interpretation of hegel yeah
it's great for that and kojev is worth
reading for
his own sake is kojev a
a good resource for like a faithful
understanding of hegel
no not really um hip elite would be the
the person from his time that you would
want to look at or
um eric vay his his uh
book on the unhappy conscience
uh unhappy consciousness sorry um
you know those would be contemporaries
of kojov they're a little bit more
on point with hegel but you know kojev
is interesting
uh gutter groan why did you pick french
instead of ancient greek for a third
language
i didn't pick a french instead of
ancient greek for a third language
my family is french-canadian so i grew
up speaking
a little bit of french because my mom
learned
english when she was five and so
spending as much time with my family you
picked up a lot of french including a
lot of swear words
and then she made me take french in
eighth grade
and tenth grade and i i resisted it as
much as possible and then i got thrown
in a french language suite in college
and i was i was cool with that because
it meant i got my own room i didn't have
to bunk with anybody
but i had to actually start learning
french grammar properly and vocabulary
and then like a whole world opened up to
me so by the time i was in grad school i
was fluent in french and reading french
i actually satisfied my language
requirement
i satisfied my language requirement
three ways in grad school
rather than two ways one was just by
sitting down
and translating from french
for i think about three hours they gave
me a text and said here you go
translate this and i was like okay and i
did it
and that was that i also
came into grad school knowing a good bit
of german being able to read german
um and then i i took classes in ancient
greek
in grad school uh with rick williams and
then dennis johnson
not not dennis johnson what was his name
i can't remember his name and then
bonnie something and i did the whole
sequence and then you know read
aristotle and plato
in in greek with these people in
independent studies
um and i learned latin on on my own
um although i had some latin when i was
in
in grade school because of the place
that i went so
so i didn't pick french instead of
ancient greek for a third language
um all right negra cornelio what do you
prefer on history of philosophy hegel
cobblestone or bertrand russell
cobblestone cobblestone is the way to go
we used him for grad school
he's a nice middle of the road
rarely gets things wrong he's not
doesn't have an axe to grind
i mean when it comes to like you know
reinterpreting the history of philosophy
russell would be less uh doing that than
hegel is hegel is definitely doing his
own shtick but russell's
work is people love it but it's not
really to be recommended
you may as well just read the the
durant's hit you know story of
philosophy if you want to do that sort
of thing
um philos why isn't hume's inquiry
taught in psychology courses
good question i don't know you'd have to
ask the psychologist that there's not a
lot of philosophy that gets taught
in psychology courses as far as i know
there's also not a lot of uh philosophy
or psychology
from it's it's you know origins that
gets taught in
uh psychology courses i i gather as well
but i don't really know
so um
let's see here
ashton says around nine years ago i lost
my faith in what i thought to be god
i've been searching for the best
justifications for a belief in god
because i feel a thirst for meaning
what are your thoughts on faith in god
and do you have any reading
recommendations for a person exploring
alternate
alternative conceptions of god i find
the religious thinkers who are the most
interesting are the ones for whom and
i've said this many times before
believing in god does not make their
life
simpler or make everything fall together
but it complicates the hell out of their
life and so i don't think you need to
like go to
alternative conceptions of god because
if you if you look around just in the
traditional theological literature
you're already gonna find all sorts of
things you're like well holy [ __ ] this
isn't what they taught us in church
alternative conceptions of god that are
closer to the say
authentic christian understanding of god
so if you read like chesterton for
example you know a great example of the
thinker that way
or if you read anselm's prayers and
meditations
you know those i think would be quite
helpful along those lines but you know
you could also explore all sorts of
other alternative things as well
somebody who i've mentioned several
times in this ama
who was really quite you know has some
really interesting ideas about god and
is exploring them philip k
dick you know i'll tell you and i i come
from a family that
uh my mom you know would watch
the last temptation of christ every year
at easter
because she said that that movie renewed
her faith
and what did that movie show you it
showed you a jesus
who um was totally human
but also also divine right who could
could suffer and and and deal with all
sorts of fantasies and not knowing what
to do at certain points and yet was god
right so sort of like that song that
i've been thinking about lately
what if god was one of us i think it had
a verse that said
a slob like one of us so yeah
all right um
despot uh genovec how would you defend
the notion of free choice against the
notion of cause and effect
which applies even to neurons in our
brain it's amazing to me
that people can be so absolutely
confident about
every single interaction of cause and
effect for stuff that they're not
observing
what have you ever seen a neuron in your
brain you might have seen neurons
when have you ever seen a neuron in your
brain how do you know that that's all
that's going on
people are so credulous when it comes to
this
this sort of thing uh so yeah
all right um let's see
let me scroll down a little bit
uh seth nikos what is your my opinion on
seneca the moral letters to lucilius is
one of the most profound things i've
read
think he's uh pretty good you know
seneca's
interesting it's it's also interesting
that the later stoics
uh don't say a thing about him like
epictetus
who could have known seneca doesn't say
a word about him
neither is marcus aurelius right um
donald robertson reads reads quite a bit
into that
um seneca was however somebody who
survived through the middle ages because
they preserved a lot of his stuff in the
monasteries the monks
really enjoyed his stuff um
let's see
what can i go out on rant about three
minutes
well here's a real quick one to line up
is there strength to the claim that
cicero may have been anti-semitic
no um as a matter of fact very few
people
cared at all about about you know the
jewish nation
uh at that time you know they were a
backwater of of rome way
located away from things um
let's see here
[Music]
let me scroll up if there's anything
that i've particularly missed
stacey s with respect to mental illness
do you buy into the theory of chemical
imbalance such that one can know the
normal chemical balance of the brain
per unique individual by x and
of the patient and can you explain why
since the reagan administration that
young black males have been
disproportionately labeled adhd
and place segregated special ed
classrooms
it's two totally separate things
do i buy into the theory of chemical
imbalance some people do have chemical
imbalances my uncle is a great example
of
that you know and do you have to like
know exactly what the balance is
no it doesn't that's not the way
psychiatry works um
you try to find something that helps to
taper things out
and and in some cases there's probably a
lot of people who've been told that
say depression is is a chemical
imbalance thing when it wasn't when it
could be treated with talk therapy or it
could be treated with other
modes or means right great book on this
uh
lost connections i'm actually i'm going
to look up the
name of the guy because it was such a
great uh book and
and he says you know sometimes people uh
john
johann hari yeah i mean he's totally
right sometimes
uh things are a result of chemical
imbalances sometimes they're a result of
environmental factors sometimes they're
a result of
other things that we can change and
nobody's claiming
at least certainly on this ama that
there's some sort of like
theory of chemical imbalance that says
that you can know
exactly what's going on on anyone's head
and you know you can talk about
uh young black males being diagnosed
with adhd
we could expand this to all sorts of
other things that have been going on
since the 90s
you know girls have been given
antidepressants because they would go
into
their psychologists and the gynecologist
would say how you feeling oh i'm feeling
kind of down here's some antidepressants
for you
ritalin was totally overprescribed not
just for uh young black males but across
the board for
young males for years and years and
years now are there other things that
can tie
in with race sure but let's not you know
let's not pretend that it's just about
that
there is a big problem with the uh you
know drug industry and the
uh mental health industry wanting to
over prescribe things for people
does that take away from the the fact
that there could be chemical imbalances
no these are these are two different
issues and both of them are worth
uh taking on all right i am going to
um sign off here
and i don't see anything i can very
easily or quickly
latch onto we'll do another one of these
ama's next month
uh tomorrow i'm i'm going to be talking
about
a political theory and application issue
about
sending kids back to school in the time
of covid19
so if you want you can join me for that
um and i'm also going to be
um doing as i mentioned uh the dr sailor
birthday bash coming up we also have the
classic heavy metal class and the worlds
of speculative fiction so a lot of
things going on this month
uh to those who wish me a happy birthday
in here thanks very much for that
thanks everybody else for joining in and
i'm gonna go get myself some some lunch
and get ready for the next thing that
i've got to do hope you have a great
rest of your day or evening or night
wherever you
happen to be